à neil leclair est une élève de 3e pas
tout à fait comme les autres
grand espoir du tennis français elle
passe la majorité de son temps sur les
courts et doit progresser dans son sport
et ses études pour voir d'où les cours
par correspondance
ils sont six âgés de 14 à 18 ans au sein
de la structure au niveau du centre val
de loire
ils sont maintenant prises en charge
directement par la ligue à laquelle ils
sont affiliés et non plus par la
fédération
quand on est en fin de match en fin de
tournoi c'est grâce au relâchement qu'on
continue d'être efficace performant
l'idée c'est d'essayer de former les
jeunes dans leur région dans leur club
au sein de leur famille pour essayer de
faire émerger des projets forts des
projets dans lesquels chacun doit
s'impliquer des cadres de lille jusqu'au
parents les enfants sont tenus de
participer à un certain nombre de
tournois et fortement incités à faire
les démarches nécessaires pour s'y
inscrire la confiance en soi elle se
travaille dès le départ comme ça en se
prenant en main c'est une volonté tout à
fait légitime d'essayer d'avoir des
vainqueurs de grand chelem 12 titres
majeurs et par rapport à ça il nous
paraît important de responsabiliser les
parents
les présidents de clubs les enseignants
les jeunes dès le plus jeune âge dans la
formation des joueurs
une vraie vie de pro pour ces jeunes
champions qui sont avant tout des
enfants un aspect à ne surtout pas
négliger
ils doivent être encadrés sur les courts
et en dehors une personne est là en
permanence pour écouter et guider j'ai
la fonction sport j'ai la fonction
scolaire j'ai la fonction aussi un peu
confidente parce qu'ils sont loin des
parents ils ont des entraînements qui
sont très difficiles le matin il se lève
très tôt
ils ont très peu de temps de repos ont
fait et qui finissent l'entraînement ils
vont à la douche on enchaîne on va
manger up après manger tout de suite
c'est temps scolaire ou à leur
entraînement
il ya très peu de pauses et c'est vrai
que des fois c'est difficile mais on est
quand même aller coûte préserver
l'intégrité physique et mentale des
jeunes une nécessité pour espérer les
amener au sommet
le haut niveau c'est quand même un
entraînement quotidien très rapidement
de la qualité c'est pas que de la
quantité c'est de la qualité c'est de la
récupération c'est un ensemble de choses
bon bah c'est ça fait partie du job du
kiné du médecin et des entraîneurs
le corps médical très à l'écouté des
jeunes énormément sollicités
physiquement le but est moins de guérir
que de prévenir sont négligés tout ce
qui est préparation et connaissance de
soi
[Musique]